I want to talk a little bit about carbon
and how it cycles through our biosphere
and we touch on this in other videos but
when we talk about elements like carbon
they don't just appear and disappear all
of a sudden our biosphere for the most
part they have been here since the
beginning but they just get recycled
from one form to another and that is
also true of carbon and to appreciate
carbons importance in our biosphere and
especially to life I have some some
important molecules or examples of
important molecules that involve carbon
and all of these the carbon are the
carbons are these dark gray colors so
this right over here this this molecule
this is glucose glucose simple sugars
it's it's where we can derive a lot of
our energy from this is ATP you could
view it as a more immediate store of
energy in biological systems this right
over here is is one of many amino acids
the amino acids make up our proteins
this right over here is DNA and in all
of these you can see the role that
carbons playing in fact sometimes the
carbon is hard to see because it's
closer to the center of these molecules
because the carbon for the most part
forms a backbone because carbons is
really neat this really neat element
this really neat atom that can make four
bonds so can make these really really
really cool structures but the question
is how does carbon cycle through our
biosphere and we can get as simple or as
complex as we want to when we discuss
this but on very very simple terms and
this is how my brain tends to think
about the carbon cycle you can imagine
the carbon in our atmosphere that's
mainly in the form of molecular carbon
dioxide so this right over here this is
co2
once again the carbon is in the middle
of there bonded to the two oxygens and
as much as we talk about co2 and as
important as carbon is to living systems
in fact our bodies are eighteen to
nineteen percent percent carbon carbon
by mass so it's very important for
biological illogical systems as a
as carbon is two biological systems and
the role carbon dioxide plays and things
like global warming it actually makes
them makes up a very small percentage of
our atmosphere it's only about 0.04
percent of the gas in our atmosphere
most of our atmosphere is actually
nitrogen 78% you don't talk a lot about
it and oxygen 21% and then a bunch of
other a bunch of other elements and
molecules but the very simple version of
the carbon cycle is okay you have this
atmospheric carbon dioxide molecular
carbon dioxide hanging out in the air
and you have autotrophs like plants so
let's say this is the ground and I have
a growing plant so that's a plant right
over there that's its leaf that's
another leaf and the way that plants
grow is they're able to take light
energy so that's energy coming in from
the Sun and use that energy to fix
carbon now fixing carbon sounds like a
very fancy thing but it's literally
taking that that molecular carbon
dioxide out of the air and fixing the
carbon from it to form to form these
different molecules in the plant that
help the plant they give the plants
structure that give the plant energy and
so that that mass of that plant I'm
actually in this this room I'm in
there's a house plant right next to me
it's not just growing out of I mean I
guess you could say it's growing out of
thin air but the mass isn't just
magically appearing it's taking that
mass out of the air and so that's where
so that's what allows this plant to keep
growing and so once again as I said some
of that will be in the form of proteins
amino acids it could form structural
components could there could be fats and
also some of it is energy and you could
imagine other animals that can't do this
that can't photosynthesize
well they might want to eat these plants
for that energy in other videos we
talked about the food cycle and so you
know this could be me this could be me
having a salad and I might want to eat
that plant I might want to eat the plant
for the sugar in it and maybe it's an
apple of some kind and then that gives
my body the energy to live and
and as I as I metabolize that glucose so
for example glucose is one of the
molecules that that plant can form by
taking that carbon out of the air and
then I might eat might metabolize that
glucose from that plant I just ate and
as I do that I will release carbon
dioxide so I will release the co2 back
in the air and then you can see that you
can form a cycle here the co2 gets
released by things that are metabolizing
these organic molecules and then it can
get fixed again by autotrophs which are
able to store the energy from the Sun
within in terms of these bonds by fixing
this carbon but there's other pathways
that we can have to have these cycles
for example some of the co2 it could be
absorbed into the ocean it could be
absorbed into into the ocean and the
ocean it can form carbonate and so once
again you still see the carbon right
over there carbon bonded to three
oxygens and calcium carbonate is a key
constituent in things like c s-- and
like things like seashells and over time
as the seashells break down and get
ground up and they get impacted with
pressure and over they can form they can
form limestone so this right over here
is limestone lime stone but once again
it fought it it was formed from carbon
dioxide being absorbed in the ocean
living living things using that calcium
using the calcium carbonate the
carbonated in conjunction with calcium
in order to form these shells which gets
ground down and it actually forms these
Rock structures you can have situations
you can have situations where living
things whether we're talking about the
autotrophs like plan so we're talking
about things like me that are eating the
plants that well once they die and
there's all this organic matter that
hasn't been broken down yet well it gets
buried in the ground I'll do the plant
because it's less morbid than showing me
dead and then so let's say this is the
plant well with enough pressure and time
sometimes in the dica in the decomposing
process some
of the carbon might be released but over
time this might be compressed and be
turned into fossil fuels so when you
when you see oil or when you are burning
gasoline which is really just a refined
part of the oil it is really this
organic matter that was that storing
energy that plants were able to store
from light energy possibly millions or
tens of millions of years ago but then
if you were to take that same if you
were to take that fossil fuel out of the
ground which we now do very actively
into in order to power all of the things
that we need to power and you were to
burn it so let me see if I were to let
me just draw an example of that so let's
say that you just had if you had a
canister of oil I can do the oil in
black because you could have you'd have
trouble seeing it and if you were to
burn it if you were to burn it the
process of the process of combustion and
this is in general if you're burning
anything it doesn't just have to be oil
it could be burning a piece of wood
you're taking that you're taking that
organic matter those carbon carbon bonds
and in some ways you could say you're
doing the reverse of the photosynthesis
process you're breaking it down and in
that process you're releasing that
carbon as getting released in the form
of carbon dioxide carbon dioxide which
in theory could then be fixed once again
so the general idea
autotrophs like plants when they when
they photosynthesize they can fix that
carbon and then it could either be burnt
and with then a combustion process can
release that carbon back into the
atmosphere or you could have other
animals eating that plant and then as
they metabolize as they break these
carbon carbon bonds to power themselves
or to just do whatever they need to do
that also can release carbon dioxide